and joining us now if his reaction is
the host of the Michael Noel's show
Michael Knowles Michael what say you
about that well you know how I can tell
Chuck Todd is lying is that his mouth is
moving Chuck Todd says there is no
left-wing media bias Chuck Todd began
his own career as a Democrat political
operative the numbers don't lie
we know that 7% of journalists identify
as Republicans 90% of negative of
network news coverage of President Trump
is negative 96% of 2016 political
donations from journalists benefited
Hillary Clinton those numbers don't lie
Chuck Todd does and now he's telling big
tech to lie because big tech has already
admitted their left-wing bias Jack
Dorsey of Twitter admitted his bias two
weeks ago okay but it's strong to say
that just on his lying I mean I'm not
sure he's lie he may be in the denial
about the problems that the mainstream
media has with bias but I think it's a
stretch to say he's lying respectfully
ed I think he is lying I think he knows
all of those numbers about the bias and
he's covering them up and I think that
he knows that big tech has admitted
their own bias we know that the news
curators at Facebook admitted that they
regularly covered up conservative
stories and suppressed them we know that
they regularly boosted left-wing stories
and this is hurting their bottom line I
think that's the big point here which is
that when you go woke you go broke and
for the first time ever
Facebook's usership has declined this
year for the first time a Twitter's
usership has dropped dramatically and
the pardon me one second I had of the
testimony to your point Jack Dorsey was
doing that media tour he talked to her
own Sean Hannity talk to Lester Holt at
NBC and acknowledged that they've had a
bias to the left and that they're trying
to do something here's what he said on
Twitter we acknowledge our
responsibility and commit to greater
accountability I plan to share our
learnings and the proactive measures
we're taking we're gonna listen learn
and engage in any practical ideas we
hear on how to improve together looking
forward to the conversation okay on one
hand maybe that sincere on the other
hand it might have been written by some
PR person saying hey we're
gonna have a conversation what are they
gonna actually do about bias and will
these lawmakers finally pin them down
that's right it's just words words words
until they actually do something about
it I hope that the lawmakers on Capitol
Hill can pin them down but I think that
big tech should take a look at their own
bottom lines because they're more than
willing they're more than able to follow
the mainstream media down this path of
censoring conservatives of denigrating
half of the country but if they do
they're gonna wind up like the
mainstream media which is to say largely
tuned out and irrelevant and what about
Congress finally pressing these tech
giants on the algorithms they always
fall back on well we've got these
algorithms complicated and they won't
tell us the actual formula so they it
seems to me that at least sometimes they
hide behind that to blame the algorithms
for why you see certain things in your
Facebook feed over other things
that's exactly right the big issue here
is transparency we're not asking them to
become big conservatives all of a sudden
we just want some transparency and
that's where the lawmakers can come in
because big tech has always said we're
an open platform
we're not publishers we shouldn't be
regulated like publishers but if they're
curating if they're suppressing
conservative views if they're boosting
left-wing views then they're behaving
like publishers and they should be
regulated as such yeah and and so moving
forward I think you're making a very
important point here which is the tech
giants have told us for so long the
whole idea of Twitter the whole idea of
Facebook I thought in part was not just
connecting but transparency people
telling you about their lives you're
getting to see records you know wide
open and and they're taking you behind
the scenes and all of that and yet when
we want to know about the algorithms all
of a sudden we're in the dark they tell
us they can't tell us that's exactly
right the whole aspect of social media
that has so benefited our discourse is
that it finally cracked up the monopoly
of the mainstream media it allowed
people to get their views whatever those
views may be out unvarnished undistorted
big tech now is is changing that and
it's a real shame we'll be watching this
testimony closely Michael knows thanks
for the preview